à deux ans du premier coup de pelleteuse
le tracé de la ligne b entre entre la
riche et chambray suscite encore des
débats mais pour la métropole plus le
temps de tergiverser sur des images de
synthèse elle donne à voir le visage des
futurs quartiers traversés par le tram
et si des consultations sont prévues ce
sera pour quelques points sensibles
comme la place jean jaurès romain des
villes le président de la métropole
considère que le tracé de la deuxième
ligne de tram ou et déterminé wilfrid
choix se maintenant instaurait ce qu'il
nomme un dialogue continu jusqu'à la fin
de l'année pour recueillir les remarques
les ajustements des habitants et des
usagers
à propos du parcours du futur tram à
partir de maintenant le dialogue avec
les citoyens peut se poursuivre très
précisément rue par rue pour voir
l'impact de ce tracé l'améliorer je
crois d'exemple la question des
stationnements véhicule pour pour les
commerçants je veux dire ça parfaitement
légitime il faut que le tracé soit
étudié le plus finement possible pour
que la nos commerces puissent se vivre à
l'issue de ce de ces tracés de tramway
c'est un enjeu majeur
parmi les sujets de discussion la rue de
la mairie à la riche ou encore la place
jean jaurès où les fontaines devrait
laisser place au futur tramway
on va lancer une grande concertation sur
la place jean jaurès donc qu'on
appellera la place dans tous les états
l'objectif c'est de travailler à la fois
bien sûr avec les techniciens avec les
élus mais surtout et beaucoup avec les
habitants qu'ils donnent leurs envies
leurs souhaits sur l'évolution de cette
place et ce qui permettra de nourrir
l'appel à projets et le concours
d'architecte que l'on qui sera établi en
fin d'année cette période de
consultation technique et populaires ne
prend pas la place de l' enquête
publique qui elle se tiendra en 2022